huge news this morning guys the Fox
Disney merger has been voted on and both
companies Fox and Disney have approved
that means the MCU just got a lot bigger
so this morning the shareholders for the
Walt Disney Company and the shareholders
for the 21st Century Fox company got
together and voted on whether or not
they wanted to approve the deal
according to the report 99% of Disney
shareholders voted YES to the
acquisition fox shareholders came
together as well and enough of them
voted yes to approve the deal you only
need over 50% so 51% of the shareholders
voting YES approves the deal which is
what happened so seventy 1.3 billion
dollar deal finally approved giving
Disney ownership and rights to movie
franchises such as predator avatar
diehard planing of the Apes but most
importantly what we all really only care
about is that they finally own and have
the rights to the x-men and the
Fantastic Four this opens up the next
phase of the MCU to be just completely
ridiculous there's been reports that
Disney has already been slightly
involved with the x-men and that they're
not very pleased with it and actually
yesterday we got a report that the Dark
Phoenix x-men Dark Phoenix and the new
mutants are probably being scrapped but
now with the deal going through this
opens these movies up to be done by the
writers producers and directors that we
know and love at Disney and Marvel but I
think what everybody is just really the
most excited about is that in the next
phase of the MCU we could have the x-men
the Avengers and the Fantastic Four all
teaming up together on screen
we're already blown away with Avengers
infinity war and with Avengers 4 with
all these characters coming together for
the first time imagine another infinity
war but with all the characters we have
now and Professor X thrown in there Jean
Grey thrown in there Wolverine the Human
Torch mr. fantastic imagine all
these people in one movie it's gonna be
ridiculous so that's it the deal is done
just waiting on approval from the
government now and it's so exciting the
next phase of the MCU with all these
characters is just going to be
ridiculous the x-men and the Fantastic
Four are coming home thank you all so
much for the support that you give me
and this channel it really means
everything to me I'm so excited for the
next years to come if you're new to this
channel and you love Marvel DC and
everything superhero I'd love for you to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything as always really all thank
you so much for watching thank you for
the support woof woof
[Music]